you went to the staffer in charge right
and asked for help and he Jacmel put me
and put me in a child control position
which is kind of hidden his hands are
going under your arms and locking up
behind your head and he picked me up off
the ground he's over six foot tall and
got muscles the size of I would I would
say he's got a wingspan of about 130
inches it sounds like he hogtied you
kind of liked it yeah
instead of without rope and my feet from
handling yeah pretty much
why would he do this anger over stuff is
what he added like like he was stressed
himself and he just took it out on the
kids that you didn't know how to control
and went trained none of the none of the
staff they were trained right like they
were supposed to be to handle the anger
attitudes that the kids there would have
we can control did other staffers and
other campers see you at the time that
he was attacking me know that we was out
of out of the vision of everybody but
there was one person who did but she's
unavailable right now when this was
finally over
did you tell somebody about it did you
go to the authorities they I went to the
hospital and the hospital that he sent
me to the hospital for back my back pain
and more my head went through a window
told me I did he through your head
through a window yeah and he broke it my
head went straight through the window at
the time I was trying to get get my body
on the ground type you know try to
control the situation that try to at
least save myself from getting hurt any
worse how did this individual explain to
the hospital that you were there he said
I got into a fight and then the the
staff that was with me there's a wrote a
statement and it said that I was a
started by a staff I wish I was I was
there